hallo mein name ist luca und ich habe
herausgefunden dass das trio auf dem
handy gilt deswegen habe ich mir das
einfach mal auf dem ipad runtergeladen
damit ich das hier so cool ist einmal an
alle männlichen zuschauer kennen das
wenn wir euch irgendwie in der hose was
falsch liegt wenn die versuchten in der
hosentasche und das dann hinzu nicht
okay die die spielen heute ag auf dem
handy beziehungsweise auf dem ipad gibt
es die offizielle app im app store
bisher nur so eine fake scheiße das
heißt wir geben hier ist bei unseren
richtigen namen klicken dann auf öffnen
und da wo ich meinen punkt hin setzte
kann ich quasi jetzt mich ganz normal um
steuern und schauen ob ich das ganze
dann irgendwie auch gewinnen kann und
das ist jetzt auch schwer die steuerung
wo es und ich kann sogar mass effect nur
da links ist ein riesiger sowie das
nicht so schwer nein nein hat mich
gegessen der kleine pizza oder krieg
jetzt vorne und zwar man kann auch
wasserinsekten da gibt's nämlich rechts
zwei knöpfe die seht ihr da jetzt mal im
zoom eingeblendet wenn ich jetzt
beispielsweise irgendwie auf den oberen
drücke dann kann ich mich halt teilen da
so auch ich vollidiot macht das auch
noch ich es jetzt mal hier vorne
frankreich so dann haben wir vorne die
niederlande die niederlande mit der wir
immer noch eine rechnung auf habt ihr
die niederlande
nein aber wenigstens hat er die
niederlage ja ihr [ __ ] ihr kriegt mich
doch nicht mein geld hole ich mir jetzt
soll da habe ich mir ein bisschen von
ein gag geholt also es ist es ganz geil
für eine mobile version aber es ist sehr
sehr schwer zu steuern checkte ich jetzt
mal was einfach um auch um gefressen zu
werden das war wieder ein glorreicher
moment in meiner spielerkarriere spinnst
aber ganz neues dafür dass man diesen
punkt hinsetzen kann wo man will ich
könnte ihn rein theoretisch auf den
typen hier drauf setze ich kann eben
auch nach rechts setzen oder volver das
war halt in den bisherigen spielen immer
so blöd vorgegeben das heißt das fand
ich damals ein bisschen scheiße dass man
also dass hier kann man das halt quasi
selbst hin bestimmen und das ist halt
ganz cool dass ich den jetzt quasi
direkt hier unten links umsetzen kann so
wie ich mir das ist schon immer
gewünscht habe ich zu weihnachten und
allen möglichen anderen facebook habe
ich mir das immer gewünscht etwa nennt
großer bruder und jetzt kann ich hier
quasi rum stelle und so wie im ganz
normalen radio und hoffentlich mal
irgendwie dann eine norddeutschland
deutschland gibt mir deutschland gibt
mir deutschland bin ich bin wieder
zusammen und das heißt dass der mond mit
dem man auch noch eine kleine rechnung
offen aus anderen spielen
es hat ein bisschen gewackelt gib mir
den mond
die mediawatch etwas sagt man dazu hier
sind auch dankeschön kleiner grüner
punkt das coole ist es bourn hall
teilweise echt viele und die fahnen
einfach in mich rein oder sie stehen so
afk herum sowie dieser krise hier vorne
und das projekt die einfach nicht der
grüne der wir der will doch auch das war
wieder so ein richtig blöder moment
einfach und jeder denkt wie ich nur so
heißt er wirklich kann jetzt kommt hier
vorne ist jetzt der rote gespannt und
der ist aber auch viel schneller als ich
ja oder vorne ist ganz viel davon kann
ich wieder um mich rum
das ist doch nicht vater und die sind
oft fast so schnell wie ich weil ja komm
frist ich von mir das gegenseitig auch
aber nicht mich bitte kommt freunde sie
durch zusammen zieht euch zusammen ja
ihr wert dabei kommt cornelius ich
glaube an dich glauben nicht ganz ganz
toll cornelius carius kom kom kom kom
kom cornelius cornelius project vom märz
da habe ich die beiden hier gefressen
und dann fresse ich diesen gelben dahin
jetzt auch noch eben schnell und dann
sind wir auf unserem weg zum dach ganz
in aus dem tabelle damit den gelben was
jedenfalls ganz nice es ist einfach dass
ich auch guck mal mein geld gib mir gibt
michelle kleingeld danke super lieb
trotzdem muss ich irgendwie raus kommen
das war überhaupt nicht cool ich hasse
das wenn man hier wieder so ein scheiß
kleiner pisser ist und sich diese ganzen
scheiß pjsc namen scheiße hier zusammen
suchen muss das packt mich immer richtig
abzuräumen jetzt gibt mir wenigstens
ihnen hier und das ist doch alles hier
natürlich oder gebt mir ein von den
türkisen oder irgendwann kommt schon
wieder frankreich ist es dann nicht bar
können wir nicht einfach mal danke
deutschland dass wir wenigstens
zusammenhalten danke für eure
unterstützung und jetzt noch bitte
irgendwie ein riesiges den ich genau
diesen orangen da hinten kann ich mir
doch locker krallen genau dann hole ich
mir dich und jetzt wollte ich mir noch
hier den ort kommen mal johanna das war
gerade bulgarisch und da wird auch schon
gerade bei name eingeblendet [ __ ] you
ich muss tatsächlich sagen mir macht es
mehr spaß gerade offen
ich finde es auf dem pc 44 dialer love
ablief redet und nord jetzt erstmal
möchte ich hier irgendwas reißen in
dieser ganzen katar kündigt nicht
einfach mal meine blöden pista camelot
die punkte 1 ich finde die steuerung
aber zumindest schon mal ganz gut
gelungen und das ist ja eigentlich mit
das wichtigste beiden spiel
dass man dann nicht so was hat wo man
sich erst mal 1000 jahre 3 1 hin muss
danke dafür dass du dich essen durfte
was ihr mit mir in die kommentare
schreiben könnte wenn den bock darauf
haben wie kann ich jetzt dieses grüne
ding auf diesen riesigen das schleudern
wie ist das möglich mir wird das mal
gezeigt dass es irgendwie funktionieren
soll
ich habe das auch in videos gesehen aber
ich habe überhaupt keine ahnung wie es
funktioniert wie gefällt euch das
allgemein würdet ihr sagen das ist ganz
nice dafür dass es halt nur ein handy
version light version ist wenn er euch
hab grad ein tinnitus war scheiße würdet
ihr sagen das ist für so eine kleine für
so ein kleines game oder online da
wollte ich ihn austricksen und dass er
zu mir hinkommt aber dann habe ich immer
nur mich selbst gegeben und jetzt ist
jeder hier auf meinen fersen
ob die türkei wie groß bist du denn nein
die noch dichte ich kriege ich doch und
barmen und jetzt bin ich wieder so blöd
wie gewesen wie scheiße dies can't be
true geht gemäss am 3
jetzt werde ich dir schon wieder von der
ganzen match erfolg hier den mars dauert
und kriege ich doch locker noch achtung
hier bist danke maß danke dass du dich
noch kriegen durfte hier vorne haben wir
doch bestimmt auch noch welche nee aber
jetzt bin ich wieder zusammen und jetzt
gehen wir aufs ausland ging und zwar
dichter vorne hole ich mir jetzt hole
ich mir da unten noch im pinken oder
kanada das ist mir eigentlich dann auch
schnuppe hauptsache ich komme jetzt
irgendwie mal wieder hier in die top ten
hier kommen die pink nach vorne hole ich
mir das ist jetzt auch nicht so schwer
oder kom kom kom der factor und naja als
ob wir gleich groß sind
das ist doch nicht wahr wir sind niemals
gleich groß ich bin viel größer ist es
doch nicht wahr ich bin noch wirklich
größer oder also vergleichbar meine
unsere mit sein das ist doch einfach nur
gemein dass es jetzt nicht geht als ob
wir gleich groß sind ja jakits das ist
meine chance zu scheinen
oh mein gott ich bin groß ich bin groß
friends so erstmals splitten und die
ganzen sticker hier vorne ein fressen
die mich wohl fressen wollten das habt
ihr nämlich davon don't [ __ ] [ __ ] you
also [ __ ] euch weil ich und faktor und
ich bin riesig
ja kommt in meinen mund
ihr habt keinen kommen und euch da vorne
und es und die ich da vorne und jetzt
das ist doch ihr seid doch nein du
kriegst mich nicht du frisst mich nicht
grüner nein
nein du da unten ich ja sollten wir dich
noch eben gekriegt hier kommen meine
ganzen kumpanen wieder
dann entdeckte ich wieder sammlers und
dass ich definitiv nicht in den blauen
reingehen sondern den gelben hier unten
hole ich mir man kann hier wenigstens
mit seinem ich bin am arsch ich bin
vollkommen am arsch man kann doch weg
duca kratze ich finde mit ein bisschen
geduld kann man hier definitiv mehr
reissen als zum anderen agiere so jetzt
als anfänger oder so und ist halt
einfach fürs handy das ist megageil und
die belichtung in diesem video ist total
scheiße oder ich wollte das video
eigentlich nicht so lange hat jetzt bin
ich froh dass ich wieder bei 20 minuten
jetzt natürlich nachher wieder runter
halten kürzen
allerdings glaube ich dass ich mich
jetzt für irgendwen spenden werde ich
weiß nur noch nicht für wen kommen
freunde wisst ihr was ich gehen den
grünen kannst mich auf essen jetzt haben
wir hier einen typen pro-ge wächst lässt
das wollen wir das ist cool wenn es euch
gefallen hat und ihr habt bock auf mehr
dann abonniert meinen kanal ich bin
nicht immer so beschreibt eigentlich
schon ich würde mich auch über eine
bewertung freuen und wir sehen uns in
einem nächsten video wieder